veamos si podemos comparar la fracción
cinco tercios con diez séptimos y
descubrir cuál de estas fracciones es
más grande y ustedes pueden darse cuenta
de que estas dos fracciones son más
grandes que un entero aquí un entero
sería tres tercios pero tenemos cinco
tercios y aquí un entero sería siete
séptimos pero tenemos diez séptimos
bueno para saber cuál de éstos es más
grande voy a dibujar ambas fracciones en
esta recta numérica y los invito a qué
pausa en el vídeo y traten de hacer esto
mismo pero por su cuenta y después ver
cómo lo solucionamos aquí tenemos esta
recta numérica con un 0 un 1 y un 2 y lo
primero que hice fue dividir esta recta
numérica en tercios en terceras partes
tenemos un tercio aquí son dos tercios
estas terceras partes están marcadas en
azul y pueden ver que este espacio del 0
al 1 está dividida en tres partes
iguales 1
a 23 y el espacio entre el 1 y el 2
está también dividido en tres secciones
iguales y como pueden ver estoy marcando
en azul todos los tercios
este es un tercio dos tercios este es
tres tercios o un entero aquí tengo
cuatro tercios
aquí cinco tercios
y si llegamos aquí el 2 va a ser lo
mismo que 6 tercios pero lo que nos
interesa es cinco tercios
qué es esta de aquí y ahora pensemos en
séptimos y para pensar en séptimos
divide el espacio entre el 0 y el 1 en
siete partes iguales lo vemos aquí 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 tenemos siete secciones iguales
este es un séptimo aquí dos séptimos
tres séptimos cuatro séptimos cinco
séptimos seis séptimos y siete séptimos
lo escribimos aquí el entero es lo mismo
que siete séptimos ocho séptimos nueve
séptimos diez séptimos y esa es la
fracción que nos interesa justo aquí
diez sobre siete y vemos que tanto diez
séptimos como cinco tercios están en la
sección que va del 1 al 2 pero cuál de
estos dos es más grande vemos que es
cinco tercios está más alejado hacia la
derecha comparado con 10 séptimos vamos
a hacer que esto resalte un poco más
estos 10 séptimos
está justo aquí y cinco tercios está a
la derecha de 10 séptimos
por lo tanto cinco tercios es más grande
que 10 séptimos como vamos a escribir el
símbolo recordemos que la parte de la
abertura debe de estar del lado del
número más grande y como cinco tercios
es el número más grande la abertura debe
estar de su lado y la parte más pequeña
o esta puntita debe de estar del lado
del número más pequeño por lo que
tenemos que cinco tercios es mayor que
10 séptimos